[Music]
there are a lot of celebrities come on
this show and I have a six year old and
an eight year old and I tell them you
know I'm gonna go see this story that
started they don't know who I'm talking
about I don't know what it is but I told
my kids today I'm gonna go see Ringo
Starr today and they lost their minds
kids today young kids know you and love
you explain that I'm lovable I don't
know it's the thing that's always being
a fact that I get on with kids right and
I feel that's because I am one right you
know what I mean it's uh I say that to
my son and he doesn't laugh either he's
got his own kids that say now you've got
someone to play with you don't eat yeah
you I saw your you play with your
all-star band a number of years ago when
we were doing the show in New York and I
went inside Radio City and you were nice
enough to invite me backstage just to
chat and just before you went on you
told me that you still get stage fright
I do I don't believe that I find that
I'm gonna lie to you there's moments
every night there's a moment that I just
want to go back to bed it's like oh it's
I just got nervous and then I run on
yeah and as soon as I got the mic then
I'm fine but every night I keep saying
okay tonight's the night you're gonna be
Frank Sinatra you're just gonna stroll
along and I haven't made it yes you
think I wrote
you always run out everyone yeah it's
just something that happens you know all
the nerves just come to the fore but
it's so funny because after all the
insanity that you went through in the
eye of that hurricane and over all these
years to still have that but you might
need that too to put on a good show
don't you think well it's part of what I
am yeah just out of habit so I you know
it's really a come on talk to so anyone
doesn't have it this is just how I you
know you know there has been times when
not only did though I have those
hesitant
three seconds I have actually puked
before why not just did you puke
backstage just now I gotta be honest no
cuz I could have sold that on eBay well
anyway it's just one of those things I
do get nervous before every show and I
run on and I'm fine right the I want to
ask about the all-star band over the
years you get to have so many great
musicians in your all-star band and you
pretty much get to have anybody that you
want and you ask them they come and they
play with you yeah and I'm curious over
all the years George Paul they never you
never you never invited them along or
they never you didn't I did I used to
invite George every time and he'd say
you definitely give me all the money
and Paul's always busy I don't know I'll
talk to him yeah alright one of those
things you do can I ask you a I know
you've answered a million Beatle
questions all the time but I have to ask
you there's one story that I've never
thought I've always wondered is this
true or is this just one of those things
that was made up but there's a famous
story that Bob Dylan introduced you guys
to pot for the first time you never
tried it before and that's a story I
thought is that true oh it is true but
he didn't actually give is it he was in
the room so he was not the supplier no
Paul Dylan's your dealer
now bob was in the room in the hotel
when was was arranged that someone else
would bring some stuff him someone who
got high and we left our asses on do now
this was so the the the four have you
tried it for the first time who was the
one that went first or did you all I
went first how did you how did you how
was that decided the dramas always go
first more than his share how was it
decided that you would go first no just
how it was you didn't draw lots
it was a very like okay let's go you
know we had a sweet we had a living room
and in the bedroom was where it was
happening it was you know it was against
the law then not like now it's okay it's
been crazy here in California I'm not
used to it I mean people want you know
you see people driving public buses
smoking marijuana now I dramas oh okay I
don't think so okay I apologize mr. Eko